which one is faster mac or pc well today
we will find out once in for all with
this custom built water cooled pc that
has an intel 12 900k and an rtx 3090
just like what apple compared the mac
studio to on stage at their event and
we're gonna see did apple really
exaggerate all those numbers saying that
this matches it or beats it
it's gonna get interesting and some
tests yes another test no and i'm going
to do a bunch of real world tests not
only some benchmarks i want to see how
well does it do as far as coding 3d
rendering video editing photo editing
responsiveness and a lot more so let's
go ahead and jump right in the first
thing i have to mention are some key
differences of course this pc is big
it's a standard tower you have room for
a triple liquid cooling system you have
expandability you have slots you can
actually swap out yourself instead of
ones that are locked down from apple so
that is the benefit and now with that it
is also loud we're going to talk about
power usage in a bit but the fans
they're running you can hear them and
especially when you're pushing that
either the graphics card or the cpu and
both at once it takes off like a jet
engine to cool itself down now the mac
studio on the other hand it is tiny
incredibly tiny i'll just grab it like
this
you can literally take this with you if
you have a monitor at home monitor at
work or wherever they actually sell a
bag for this so that is another benefit
but you don't get expandability now as
far as ports this can go both ways
because for the pc you can buy a
motherboard that does not have
thunderbolt like the one that mark used
by the way thank you mark for letting us
use your awesome pc for this testing and
you can spend a lot more money to get
things like thunderbolt 10gb ethernet
which all do come with the mac studio
this one has six thunderbolt ports 10
gig ethernet built in plus the sd card
reader so total pricing if you end up
specking it out the same as far as ram
with really fast ddr5
uh and storage with really fast
comparable storage they currently are
roughly around five grand each because
pc parts are also inflated so you kind
of have to get lucky to buy one of these
30 90s jumping into performance i was
shocked by how snappy this system was it
scored 290 in speedometer 2.0 which is
insanely fast now the mac did beat it at
300
but man when you're doing anything
online on the system installing stuff
i've never felt a windows pc that was
this fast and that's because a single
core actually beats out the mac studio's
m1 ultra almost 2 000 points incredible
performance and when we switch to
multi-core which runs about 30 different
tests it does get beat out by about 6
000 points in favor of the mac studio so
we have more power for a variety of
simple quick tasks now when we jump into
cinebench which maxes out the cpus well
here the 12 900k actually beats out by
about 2500 points we have more raw
performance now when it's doing that the
fans just go crazy even during geekbench
the multi-core score that's because this
thing once actually settles down uses
about 210 watts compared to 58 on the
mac studio with the m1 ultra
so that is a lot more power actually
peaks higher than that but it also runs
super hot because in order to get that
much performance out of the intel chip
it needs a lot of power actually more
power than the cpu and gpu combined uses
in this system now one thing that we
have found is that with apple silicon
once you start scaling up to such high
core counts we are getting some
bottlenecks with software for example
with this cinebench where it scored 24
000
it actually is not using as much
capabilities as it could and we were
also told that it's using an intel based
back end so with like the m1 chip it
scored really well
it's not as limited because of like
translation or anything else but with
these you start hitting it more we're
going to come up to this
with other tests whereas with some
real-world programs that are fully built
surprisingly adobe lightroom if you
actually use more wattage and get more
performance now before we jump into the
real world stuff we have to talk about
the graphics so this has a 64 core
version of the m1 ultra compared to the
rtx 3090 with its own 24 gigabytes of
dedicated memory
now in geekbench that thing scores 233
000 points as far as the cuda score
compared to 102
massive difference over double how can
the mac studio compete
well once again
there's issues where it's not actually
utilizing the gpu all the way
which is why we have such a big gap in
performance but in other programs that
do fully utilize the capabilities like
gfx bench here it got
485 frames per second in the off screen
test so that means it's not going to be
affected by resolution now the rtx 390
got 514 so it did beat it out but it's
not more than double the score now this
shows you the gaming performance of the
gpu so it is very close to the rtx 3090
but of course the issue is there are no
games and some people are testing things
like shadow of the tomb raider but
that's running an intel version with
rosetta bottle licking like crazy of
course if you want to play games you
definitely should buy the pc now on the
flip side the mac studio is the way to
go for people that code it is insanely
good it actually beat out the 28 core
xeon in the mac pro which literally
costs four times as much money and it's
quite a bit faster but of course the
windows pc cannot run xcode but matthew
moniz did an excellent test where he
compiled mozilla firefox on both
and the mac studio was
almost twice as fast huge gap in
performance so that is insane now as far
as 3d rendering well we have the latest
version that was released of blender and
here we tested party tug with the ev
rendering engine which is nice for quick
previews and
well the mac studio got smoked we have
four and a half seconds compared to 2.8
very quick on the pc now for high
quality renders you want to use a cycles
engine both do support gpu compute
and here the max studio got a minute and
65 seconds that's way faster than cpu
but
guess how fast the pc was with the rtx
3090 i was using optix so it's the
fastest engine
my mind was blown go ahead and comment
down below
all right it took
15 seconds
compared to a minute and six seconds
that is absolute insanity
how in the world is it set that fast
well first off blender isn't that
efficient he is running metal but it's
like a translation layer almost like
you're using crossover to translate it
like an emulator basically so it's not
very efficient and we should be getting
an update that's actually
built for metal with a new engine
that'll make a lot faster but even when
that comes the pc is gonna be a lot
faster because you have those ray
tracing cores there that are insanely
insanely fast so
if you want to do 3d rendering and you
care about speed definitely go for the
pc
now for those of you guys that work with
images
let's see what we get we have a test
here with 42 megapixel raw images with a
bunch of different effects applied and
man the pc was quick it exported these
to jpeg in 62
seconds
very very fast super impressive but
the mac studio did it in 45
seconds insane performance compared to
previous macs including high-end mac
pros now we also tested out a panorama
these are actually 50 megapixel raw
files we have nine images
the mac studio took 34 and a half
seconds compared to 45.5
seconds so for photo editors it doesn't
matter if you're doing simple things in
photoshop you're doing lightroom you're
merging stuff
the mac studio is super fast and it's
pretty much because of the unified
memory even though the pc has 5600
megahertz ddr5 very fast having it on
the chip right there with the processor
makes it so snappy and has a lot more
channels the way it's designed now
getting into video editing i actually
use premiere pro davinci resolve and
final cut of course final cut just on
the mac to show you guys an honest true
picture of what's happening with a
variety of codecs as well and what does
better depending on what you do now the
first thing that people are asking for
is de-noising and davinci resolve
because this will just hit the gpu
and it won't factor in the media engines
apple is using that are great it won't
factor in cpu the ram it just hits your
graphics now here
denoising 4k
24 frames per second black magic raw
with some tough temporal and spatial
noise reduction
uh we got 19 to 20 frames per second
much better than the m1 max that gets 11
to 12 a lot more performance not double
though
but the pc with the rtx 3090 was able to
get a perfect 24 frames per second not
only that it only uh used 80 of that gpu
meaning we have extra power so
that gives it about 40 percent more raw
graphics performance for video editing
but of course that doesn't include all
the things that apple packed into this
for smoothness of timeline and exporting
so with standard footage none of these
will ever have an issue super smooth and
the mac studio is way faster
than the windows pc now yes we are using
the rtx 3090s nvenc encoding engines for
all of these tests and just because
people say this has unfair advantage
because it has the special
media engines well the windows pc that
graphics card also has it as well as a
new 12 gen cpu which really helps on a
couple of these tests but the mac is
just on a whole other level now one
thing i want to point out is the fact
that resolve was so much faster than
final cut and premiere pro with the mac
now that is because it looks like final
cut is not utilizing all the performance
here it's only used to be using half of
the encoders and decoders because apple
did not release the version of final cut
that they advertised on stage and they
put in their fine print they gave all
the reviewers that version but not to us
and they're not even letting you guys
get the beta version so it's been you
know about a week now and we don't have
it so resolve they actually updated it
and they're getting all the performance
but the mac is definitely faster for
most of you guys that do simple editing
with 4k
now as far as raw power for
stabilization
we have an insane score and final cut it
has just been way faster and as far as
davinci resolve the mac is also faster
than the pc and this actually maxes out
your gpu and davinci resolve so the
efficiency with unified memory helps
here and in premiere pro it's just cpu
based only about 30 of the cpu and it's
slower on the mac and now let's finish
off with some tougher tests here we have
canon r5 footage this thing started like
crazy on my mac pro it stutters on most
computers but intel's 12 gen it has the
decoders for it so now it is great and
it takes 2 minutes and 38 seconds in
premiere and davinci resolve now on the
mac it takes 2 minutes
definitely faster and on final cut it's
actually slower almost three because
they have not updated it come on apple
what are you guys doing
now of course these are shorter projects
because we test and retest it takes so
long but neither of these systems
throttle even though
the windows pc
it gets be very hot and very loud and
the mac it runs at 50 to 60 degrees
celsius for cpu gpu so no throttling so
if you have an hour project you guys
could just scale up the differences now
for those of you guys that are working
with prores the mac is in killer it has
dedicated hardware to decode an encode
so it's not putting any stress on the
cpu to do that we have an insane
difference between the mac and the
windows pc and in davinci resolve it
literally takes 50 seconds to export
this 8k to 4k project because it's been
updated for the encoders but even
without that we see a huge difference
now i'm not exporting to prores because
you can't do that on a windows pc so
it's going to h.265
to keep it fair
but if you're working with pro res you
have to get a mac that has this hardware
now going to the toughest test that's
going to max out your cpu and your gpu
this is 8k red raw as far as playback
they are actually very very close in
premiere pro both can run it perfectly
at half resolution in an 8k timeline
davinci resolve you can also set the
option so i was really surprised this is
the first time that a mac can actually
compete with this high-end rtx graphics
card as far as smoothness and all of
these tests they they're super close
now when we go to export it the mac is a
lot faster in premiere pro and davinci
resolve
literally being insanely fast in
premiere for some reason premiere uh is
really great for red footage in final
cut it's definitely the slowest as far
as the mac it still hasn't been updated
once again which is just dumb at this
point
but you guys can see the differences
between the mac and pc so clearly for
video editing as long as you're only
using one gpu on your pc instead of two
or three or four
this mac studio is awesome and the cool
thing is if somebody does video editing
or you're on set you're doing cuts you
could take so much power with you in
your hand like this
now for 3d rendering gaming definitely
pc but for coding for photo editing
for
other things like video editing
this thing does do a great job now was
apple correct in some of their charts
and some yes some seemed a little bit
off uh and hopefully we do get more
updates as far as optimization and new
rendering engines being built for this
to speed it up but overall i thought
that the mac would get smoked in some of
these tests where it held its ground
pretty dang well so you guys let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section below check out one of those
great videos right over there subscribe
above to help us reach your goal of a
million subscribers if you guys
appreciate it we have tons of videos
coming this has been max and i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
you